they censor and suppress they're
regarded back to 2016. this is all
because of the giant
fake russia hoax all of this comes from
the lie
that donald trump and the russians
colluded to steal the election of 2016.
and then how do we get from there to
there because all of this censorship
comes from that you know whatever you're
saying that disagrees with the party
line this is russian disinformation
you're not just wrong this is dangerous
and you're a de facto agent of a foreign
power and all this
so this is when they really started
de-ranking people from google searches
uh when they really started kicking
people off of twitter and facebook
and just like with the germ here for
getting things exactly right
for saying that the russia hoax was
absolutely a hoax wasn't a traitor he
was a loyal american patriot and let's
talk about exactly right
when tucker brought up lab leak he
didn't definitively state
it was or wasn't he said these are
interesting questions he was exactly
right to ask those questions
which are now being admitted to by
fouchy but the media said it was a lie
you can't trust these people right and
so and you know i know a lot of people
that they love watching this show
i i i uh there's there's a bias fact
checker thing that people were posting
and it was really funny it said that tim
on twitter tim poole has a has a
right-wing blind spot meaning
most of the stories i i tweet about are
from the left but it's because
mainstream media is the left so i use
newsguard which i referenced earlier
rather angrily
they certify what is or isn't factual
news that they'll be like oh this
website has bad standards and has good
standards
daily wire is rated as having bad
standards it's a conservative opinion
website
that what what they report on is fact
based it's just their opinions their
opinions can be wrong
right media matters which is just
activism
is rated green across the board right so
it's not that i have a left bias it's
that
the organizations the institutions have
an institutional
left establishment bias a liberal bias
right they hate the left
they'll go after them persecute real
leftists you know they they um
they'll use them yeah once they started
kicking all the right wingers off of
twitter
then they went well no but and d ranking
them on google
they said no but we're being fair
because we're also picking on the left
too and they went after truth dig truth
out
the world socialist website which is the
trotskyites
and they threw antiwar.com in there even
though we're libertarians i guess they
just assume we're leftist so we got
deranked by google along with everybody
else
in the name of fairness because they're
picking on these people
but they didn't kick the liberals off
they kicked the leftists that's right
the occupy wall street activists got
banned i saw you you guys got listed in
uh a it was a blacklist of some sort
probably google and i remember talking
to a bunch of conservatives being like
dude they're going after the people who
oppose the establishment
right it's not they'll they'll gleefully
use the leftists
and unfortunately a lot of a lot of
these young leftists
don't know who these people are they
don't they weren't they weren't around
in politics when joe biden was vice
president
so they think he's the hero or or to be
fair
the dsa types in the early 20s think
sure he's bad
but he's not a fascist and i'm like i
got news for you about the biden
obama years and what biden was doing
with his brother so make sure
call them whatever you want crooked how
about that but they weren't around for
it yeah so they vote for this guy
they get exploited and that's why
democrats love younger voters
a 16 year old doesn't have the memory of
what they did 10 years ago right
exploitation that's the name of the game
so they'll censor
everybody but here here's what ends up
happening trump
was very powerful in terms of upsetting
the establishment
trump's followers were very prominent
and influential
they had to get rid of those people they
cut it they smack it from the middle
and then trump loses a lot of his core
uh
evangelizers these these prominent
personalities that means less grassroots
you know people rising up they ban
subreddits like the donald this massive
subreddit where people are posting memes
and having a good time
they cut it out from the ground up and
then trump falls
they had to go after him with all of
their force that means the conservatives
were getting the brunt of the censorship
but there were very much so many
leftists who were anti-establishment as
well
and screaming and saying few to the
democrats the whole way
and they got nuked too but there were
there were fewer of them
so what ends up happening is the whole
narrative becomes conservative
the liberals end up just saying it's a
fake it's fake news conservatives are
lying it's a private company
and then many leftists who get banned
apparently weren't loud enough because
leftists are always fighting with each
other as well
a lot of leftists decided to align
themselves with democrats because
as they described it it's easier to
overthrow a feeble old man than it is a
fascist so they decided they were going
to support joe biden
for some reason they didn't then speak
up for their for their own
or if they did and this is the problem a
conservative gets banned
the leftist laughs the leftist gets
banned and then demands the
conservatives stand up for them
and the conservative does some
conservatives started saying you know
what screw you i'm gonna laugh as you
get canceled
but this is the problem of censorship it
is the democratic establishment and the
old neocon establishment which got
fractured as soon as trump stormed into
the party but all those people the
lincoln project people are very much
still aligned with all of the democrats
they've become one big they've always
been one big uniparty
but now there's like real opposition
fomenting
and ultimately i think the censorship
will get worse
i think it'll impact us we've talked a
great deal about it
the the lab leak theory we weren't
allowed to talk about you know we were
we'd be very careful in talking about it
and now here we are with fauci himself
deciding it's okay and now now it's okay
yeah well you know i think it's really
one of the major crises of our era is
the left
the the further left really giving up on
freedom of speech
and and bringing the liberals with them
you know it used to be the liberals were
the ones who would go to court to fight
for your right to say whatever you want
that they disagree with but
because they really don't yeah they've
taken really much more of a
totalitarian uh sort of a left you know
my friend anthony gregory says
it used to always be the best thing
about the left was that they weren't the
liberals
and the best thing about the liberals
was that they weren't the left yeah
because you need them both right because
the liberals have made their peace with
capitalism
and and guns and i mean they're not
coming forward no no the liberals are
the
anti-gun ones the leftists love guns
yeah i don't know
the traditionally the liberals have they
have their background checks and so
forth but they're not taking them
the left disagreement listen listen
right now
the leftists on twitter are posting karl
marx under no pretext shall arms and
ammunition be surrendered
the workers must frustrate frustrate
this by force if necessary well listen
the liberals
literally banned a bunch of my guns well
that's true that there there are
some leftists who are good on guns but i
i think that those kind of quotes are
pretty rare
among among the real hard left but
especially like on things like speech
um and and war so it used to be that you
could rely on the leftists
to be against imperialism to oppose the
fbi and the cia and all these things
and you could rely on the liberals to um
you know essentially support capitalism
and not be you know the worst on
but like neo-liberal capitalism that's
right yeah absolutely right crony
corporate garbage
the hillary clinton compromise so yeah
we're talking about
we're not talking about libertarianism
we're talking about right the center
left democrats
but then what happened was trump was so
polarizing that he pushed the
leftists and the liberals together but
only for the worse
right so the liberals abandoned their
belief in free speech
so that they could collaborate with the
leftists on kicking everybody else off
and then the leftists abandoned all of
their opposition to
not all but they're in large measure
their opposition to imperialism
and to the federal police agencies
because who's protecting us from donald
trump
the fbi and the cia they love it and so
everybody rally around john brennan and
robert mueller because they're
protecting us from the big bad fascists
this is what i said because i
i was i've known i've known all of these
occupy people these these leftists
i said it was the greatest
deradicalization in the history of the
united states
when i see the the far left is from
occupy cheering for the fbi
and that's all i would do so so i'm on
facebook and i see this hacker guy
this this guy who's like literally been
to prison of opposing and
fighting you know and being a far
leftist and then he's like the fbi has
raided giuliani's office this is you
know amazing he's like finally justice
and i was like i'm so happy to see that
you stepped back from the edge
and you've come towards liberalism and
now you accept the fbi and the federal
government as your saviors and you're no
longer on the side
of committing crimes then another hacker
comes in and
and she's saying she's like yes finally
and i'm like
wow i am so impressed i remember you
sleeping on the floor of that hacker
collective
talking about how you hated the federal
government and imperialism and now here
you are cheering for it
i'm just i'm so impressed with your
willingness to finally see the light and
step away from this and they don't know
you're
being sarcastic they're like yeah thanks
they're like wow myself on the back too
well no they're not all that dumb but
it's like my point was made
and one guy's like well i we're allowed
to be happy when our enemies are getting
hurt and i was like right
you support fascists when they're doing
things you like
that makes you a fascist sympathizer
there's the door
don't say that to me about donald trump
when you scream fascism and the moment
you come in and defend
authoritarian measures from the
government i'm supposed to act like
you're special
no no no yeah you don't get to play that
game donald trump was a human molotov
cocktail
he got thrown in the room he was a bull
in a china shop he was a bona ivory
tower whatever whatever whatever you
want to say
you know call him but these people got
so wrapped up in media propaganda
they went insane they were probably
already insane
uh like being re-radicalized is easy if
you live in hate like if they hated the
government and wanted to
tear it down without like a new creation
system that they had in plan
then it's easy to take those people and
redivert their hate towards something
else like the media pushed us towards
trump they tried so much so then they
just used the hate
the establishment hated trump but i i
will i will say one thing too
what you need to keep in mind about the
left is that while
many of these leftists that i'm talking
about are my age
a lot of the support they get are from
people who are 20 who don't know
anything about this they were 10 years
old during occupy wall street
they don't know so donald trump comes
along they're teenagers
before they were born that's right
that's right and
uh they're babies you know when all the
stuff is going down uh
when when a lot a lot of these people
were babies or toddlers or kids
even if they were alive they didn't know
anything about it right so i'm like what
what makes you think voting for joe
biden is going to make things better and
we actually had a conversation with this
guy
and his response was oh i was like a
little kid i was like a teenager during
occupying anything about it
i'm like so so when joe biden takes over
overseeing the iraq war
and then all of a sudden his brother
starts getting the contracts not
suspicious to you
that's what you want to come in i i take
the i take the crazy orange man
because at the very least the abraham
accords i loved it
he he wasn't perfect firing tomahawk
missiles very bad
john bolton very bad trying
to to any degree to get troops out of
the middle east i was like just
i'll take what i can get instead we get
the the
the neocon establishment again this time
just biden
he's sitting in his little wheelchair
with his blank on his lap going
as they just pulled the trigger for him
and they just what
as soon as he gets in what do we get
missile strikes in syria unsurprising
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave
comments and super chat and we actually
will read your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you